Shun. Yeah. I gotta tell you something. Okay. Really important. Okay. We're recording right now. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. The show is starting. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, it hasn't started. But this is this is the show. Yeah, but it hasn't technically started. No, but this is it. No, of course it started because it's rolling. I know, but this isn't the show. This is the part before the show. Of course it is. No, this is the show. No, Shun, stop waiting for your life to start, man. You're in it. This is smart. Hey, you know what I did last night? I didn't even tell you guys. I went to the John Williams concert at the Hollywood Bowl. Oh, this sounds awesome. Oh, no kidding. Now I know why you didn't tell us. Yeah. Come on, John Williams. Let me tell you something. John Williams. He's still up. It sounds like a rager. It was amazing. Here's this guy, John Williams, amazing conductor. He's 89 years old. I know. We're kidding. We're of course kidding. All of the songs we love, E.T., Raiders of the Lost Ark, Star Wars, all this new stuff. It was incredible. I wanted to go to that. Now, did he do a lot of the conducting? No. He did the second half. Yeah, the first half was David Newman. Yeah. It was also great. But it was amazing. I know. I nerded out. The Mozart night that you sent me, I'm so bummed I'm not here for. Yeah, I said, Jay, let's go see Mozart. Yeah, Sean and I are going to have a classical music date under the stars. Jason Ridgley, you said, yes, you thought, because you thought it was, the thing was cutting out. You thought it was mozzarella and you were like, yes, I'm in. And then it turned out it was mozzarella. You're like, yeah, not as interesting. Fried mozzarella. It's a granddad joke you've done. Guys, today's guest. Get down to business, Sean. She's an amazing woman. I love her. She's a friend of all of ours. And boy, does she make me laugh. She's been a stand-up comedian basically her whole life. Less red, Sean, less red. Try to find a way. I don't know how to do it without reading it. And boy, do I love her. She is our God. I do love her. She means so much to us. She's done everything. She's done specials, acting gigs, hosting gigs. She does everything. Here's what I love. She's opinionated. She's fearless. She's hilarious. She's gorgeous and gay men can't get enough of her. Really? It's my friend and our friend, Chelsea Handler. Chelsea. Oh, yeah. Chelsea. There she is. My white guys in one room. That's right. We're going to get some more to join us later.
Shun。对。我得告诉你件事。好的。非常重要。好的。我们现在正在录音。是的。是的。是的。是的。节目开始了。对，对，对。嗯，还没开始。但这这就是节目。对，但从技术上讲还没开始。不，但这就是节目。不，当然开始了，因为已经在录了。我知道，但这还不是节目。这是节目开始前的部分。当然是。不，这就是节目。不，Shun，别再等着你的生活开始了，伙计。你就在其中。这很聪明。嘿，你知道我昨晚做了什么吗？我甚至都没告诉你们。我去了好莱坞露天剧场听约翰·威廉姆斯的音乐会。哦，这听起来太棒了。哦，别开玩笑了。现在我知道你为什么不告诉我们了。是啊。拜托，约翰·威廉姆斯。让我告诉你一件事。约翰·威廉姆斯。他还在坚持。听起来像是一场狂欢。太棒了。这就是约翰·威廉姆斯，了不起的指挥家。他89岁了。我知道。我们在开玩笑。我们当然是在开玩笑。我们喜爱的所有歌曲，《E.T.外星人》、《夺宝奇兵》、《星球大战》，所有这些新作品。太不可思议了。我想去那儿。他指挥了很多吗？没有。他指挥了下半场。是的，上半场是戴维·纽曼。是的。也很棒。但这太棒了。我知道。我成了书呆子。你发给我的莫扎特之夜，我没能去，真是太遗憾了。是的，我说，Jay，我们去看莫扎特吧。是的，Sean和我要在星空下进行一场古典音乐约会。Jason Ridgley，你说，好的，你以为，因为你以为是，那东西声音断断续续的。你以为是马苏里拉奶酪，你就说，好的，我参加。结果发现真的是马苏里拉奶酪。你说，好吧，没那么有趣。炸马苏里拉奶酪。这是你讲的一个爷爷辈的笑话。伙计们，今天的嘉宾。谈正事吧，Sean。她是一位了不起的女性。我爱她。她是我们的朋友。天哪，她真让我发笑。她基本上这一辈子都是个单口喜剧演员。少点红色，Sean，少点红色。试着找个办法。我不知道怎么在不读出来的情况下做到。天哪，我真爱她。她是我们的上帝。我确实爱她。她对我们意义重大。她什么都做过。她做过特别节目、表演工作、主持工作。她什么都做。我喜欢她这一点。她有主见。她无所畏惧。她非常搞笑。她很漂亮，男同性恋者对她爱不释手。真的吗？她是我的朋友，也是我们的朋友，切尔西·汉德勒。切尔西。哦，是的。切尔西。她在那儿。我的白人伙计们都在一个房间里。没错。我们稍后会请更多人加入我们。
Where are you, Chelsea? Are you at home? I am in my office. No, I'm in Las Vegas, actually. I had a show here last night. Because you're on tour. I'm on tour. So, yeah. What's the name of the tour again? The unvaccinated. What? No, it's called vaccinated and horny, Sean. We came up with that together. So I appreciate a little respect. Yes. That's right. We came up with it together. Vaccinated and ready to rumble. Is there a subtitle that says everybody should get a little prick? No, it's just the tip is the subtitle. But thank you for your thank you. I love to spitball with you guys after we already named the tour. So yes, let's keep doing this. Chelsea, thanks for joining us and thank you for bringing up with Jason's punch ups that he's actually trying to give you.
你在哪儿，切尔西？你在家吗？我在办公室。不，其实我在拉斯维加斯。我昨晚在这儿有场演出。因为你在巡演。我在巡演。所以，是的。巡演的名字叫什么来着？未接种疫苗者。什么？不，叫“接种疫苗且饥渴”，Sean。那是我们一起想出来的。所以我希望能得到一点尊重。是的。没错。是我们一起想出来的。接种疫苗，准备好大干一场。有没有副标题说每个人都应该挨一针？不，副标题只是“仅仅是尖端”。但谢谢你的谢谢。我喜欢在给巡演命名后和你们一起头脑风暴。所以是的，让我们继续这样做。切尔西，谢谢你加入我们，也谢谢你忍受Jason试图给你的那些即兴修改。
I love Jason's punch ups always. They're cheap. So are you staying in Vegas for a while or is it just one of the stops there? No, I just had a stop here. I'm headed to, I have, I'm just on tour. So it's, you know, different cities every day. Next, just all over the country, all the places you want to go. Cincinnati, Grand Rapids, Michigan, places like that. Florida, Jacksonville. Do you like constantly moving and touring? Like, does it get, or do you miss home base and being still? It's like a shark. She can't stop. I'm over. I like to, I don't like to sit still for very long. Sean came with the tour once last year, two years ago. Yeah, it was so fun. Yeah, you complained the entire time. Tell us. Yeah, let's hear it.
我总是喜欢Jason的即兴修改。它们很廉价。那你会在拉斯维加斯待一段时间，还是这只是其中一站？不，我只是在这儿停一站。我要去，我有，我只是在巡演。所以，你知道，每天去不同的城市。接下来，就在全国各地，所有你想去的地方。辛辛那提，大急流城，密歇根，诸如此类的地方。佛罗里达，杰克逊维尔。你喜欢不断地移动和巡演吗？就像，会变得，还是你怀念家和静止不动？她就像条鲨鱼。她停不下来。我结束了。我喜欢，我不喜欢长时间静止不动。Sean去年，两年前，曾随巡演去过一次。是的，太有趣了。是的，你全程都在抱怨。告诉我们。是的，让我们听听。
Oh, it was such a pain in the ass. Was he like an opening act or was he choreographer? No, no, no, this is a, no, no, I, I, I read Chelsea's book, life will be the death of me. Mostly because Chelsea called me and asked me to go on tour with her and chat about it. And she said, but she said, you actually have to read the book. Oh boy. So I read the book. So you had to learn how to read. So you had to learn how to read. Then you had to get the book.
哦，那真是太麻烦了。他是开场嘉宾还是编舞？不，不，不，这是个，不，不，我，我，我读了切尔西的书，《生活将是我的死因》。主要是因为切尔西打电话给我，让我和她一起巡演并聊聊这本书。她说，但她说，你必须真的读这本书。哦，天哪。所以我读了这本书。所以你不得不学习如何阅读。所以你不得不学习如何阅读。然后你不得不去买这本书。
But I laughed out loud. I was, you know what I was when I read that book? I was like enlightened. Like you taught me things. I brought up with you on the tour. It was incredible. I was filled with insight about who you are and why you are, all those things. And in the book, you talk about your, you know, one of the things to talk about in that book was your brother passed away when you're like nine and he was older than you. Obviously, you know, I want to ask you this, you know, something like that never leaves you and has a tremendous impact on a child of that age. But for those of us who haven't suffered like a loss like that as a child, how did that inform you going further, like through your teenage years and adulthood? And does that still inform you in certain ways? Well, I think, you know, when it happens, you just like you're a nine year old person.
但我大声笑了出来。我当时，你知道我读那本书时是什么状态吗？我感觉被启迪了。就像你教了我一些东西。我在巡演中和你提过。太不可思议了。我充满了关于你是谁以及为什么你是这样的洞察力，所有这些事情。在书中，你谈到了你的，你知道，书中谈到的一件事是你哥哥在你九岁左右时去世了，他比你大。显然，你知道，我想问你这个，你知道，像那样的事情永远不会离开你，并且对那个年龄的孩子有巨大的影响。但对于我们这些小时候没有遭受过那种损失的人来说，它是如何影响你继续前进的，比如在你的青少年时期和成年时期？它在某些方面仍然影响着你吗？嗯，我想，你知道，当它发生时，你就像你是一个九岁的人。
So you can't even really articulate what's happening or digest it in any real way. It just feels like abandonment or rejection. So you kind of pack it away and then just distract yourself for the next 35 years. Yeah. And until it fucking come in, it comes and taps you on the shoulder and then you have to address it with a professional. Like once your anger stops working for you in that way and you become too angry, which is what happened to me. Then you, you, you sit down with somebody and you're like, you pay somebody to tell you what the fuck is wrong with you, right? That's, that's a transaction. I like therapy. You're paying someone to tell you, you know, why you're acting like such a cunt.
所以你甚至无法真正表达发生了什么，或者以任何真正的方式消化它。它只是感觉像是被遗弃或拒绝。所以你把它打包起来，然后在接下来的35年里分散自己的注意力。是的。直到它该死的过来，拍拍你的肩膀，然后你必须和一个专业人士解决它。就像一旦你的愤怒不再以那种方式为你服务，而你变得太愤怒时，这就是发生在我身上的事。然后你，你，你和某人坐下来，你就像，你付钱给某人告诉你是哪里出了问题，对吧？那，那是一笔交易。我喜欢治疗。你付钱给某人告诉你知道，为什么你表现得像个混蛋。
So it was a process of just understanding that many of my behaviors were a reaction to what happened to me as a little girl and the inability to ever really healthily deal with that and digest it kind of turns you into maybe somebody that you're not or maybe it is your personality, but it makes you kind of assess yourself. Yeah. It's the gift of self-awareness. You want to reflect and go, oh, wait, is this why I'm so impulsive? Is this why I don't want to be, you know, this is why I love being single and I don't have to depend on anybody, you know, all of that stuff. All that stuff, yeah. So, yeah.
所以这是一个过程，只是理解我的许多行为是对发生在我小时候的事情的反应，而无法真正健康地处理和消化它，这会把你变成一个可能不是你的人，或者也许这就是你的个性，但它让你评估自己。是的。这是自我意识的礼物。你想反思并说，哦，等等，这就是我为什么这么冲动吗？这就是我为什么不想，你知道，这就是我为什么喜欢单身，我不需要依赖任何人，你知道，所有这些东西。所有这些东西，是的。所以，是的。
Well, I think it's amazing though because, yeah, all that therapy. Sorry, did you want to interrupt me again? Sean, let me for fuck's sake. So sorry. You know, I live for it. I live for you. Okay. So keep going. Sorry. But I want to, well, we were talking about that because so Sean came to Chicago, the Chicago theater, right?
嗯，但我认为这很棒，因为，是的，所有的治疗。抱歉，你想再次打断我吗？Sean，看在上帝的份上，让我说吧。真抱歉。你知道，我为此而活。我为你而活。好的。所以继续。抱歉。但我想要，嗯，我们当时在谈论那个，因为Sean去了芝加哥，芝加哥剧院，对吧？
Yeah. We performed at, or you interviewed me. And the whole time he was just like, you know, complaining about the flight out and he had to bring Scotty, of course, which is obviously an added bonus. Anytime you have to deal with Sean, it's better to have Scotty around because it's like his nanny. That's true. And we had a great conversation on stage, right? Yeah, it was so fun. Yeah, we had a great time.
是的。我们表演了，或者你采访了我。他全程都在，你知道，抱怨飞过去的航班，而且他不得不带上Scotty，当然，这显然是一个额外的奖励。任何时候你不得不和Sean打交道，有Scotty在身边会更好，因为他就像他的保姆。那是真的。我们在舞台上进行了一次很棒的谈话，对吧？是的，太有趣了。是的，我们玩得很开心。
And then you just kept asking me how much I was going to reimburse you for the trip. Right. By the way, still waiting. How much you make and how much you got when you sold your house? Yeah, he loves to talk about money. I love it. I love it. It's great.
然后你一直问我你要为这次旅行报销多少钱。对。顺便说一句，还在等。你赚了多少钱，卖掉房子时你得到了多少？是的，他喜欢谈论钱。我喜欢。我喜欢。这很棒。
Money makes the world go around. I like to know how it makes the world go around. Speaking of money, when you're in Vegas, do you like the tables? Do you like the slots? You got a loose slot that you prefer? Yeah, I play Blackjack a lot. Although Will and I were in Vegas once and we played craps. I had never played craps before.
钱让世界运转。我喜欢知道它是如何让世界运转的。说到钱，当你在拉斯维加斯时，你喜欢赌桌吗？你喜欢老虎机吗？你有什么偏爱的松动的老虎机吗？是的，我经常玩二十一点。虽然Will和我曾经在拉斯维加斯玩过掷骰子。我以前从没玩过掷骰子。
And that was fun because Will knew how to play craps and your other friend. What was your friend's name, Will? Beast. Mark Foreman. Beast. Beast. Yeah. You lent him money.
那很有趣，因为Will知道怎么玩掷骰子，还有你的另一个朋友。Will，你朋友叫什么名字？Beast。Mark Foreman。Beast。Beast。是的。你借给他钱。
In fact, he was like, he worked for me at the time and he still does. Works with me. But now, but he had no money and he was like, no, I don't want it. And you're like, take some money. Chelsea, just grab, push some of her chips over to him. Like, you're a beast. Just take this. And he was like, oh my God, what the hell?
事实上，他当时为我工作，现在仍然是。和我一起工作。但现在，但他没钱，他说，不，我不要。你说，拿点钱。切尔西，只是抓起，把她的一些筹码推给他。就像，你是个野兽。拿着这个。他当时说，哦，天哪，这到底是怎么回事？
Now, when we worked on tour two, I was, I'm just fascinated with your family and your upbringing because there's some crossover into mine too about how kind of just screwed up it was. But I remember you telling me that your mom, no, no, wait, your dad was, is Jewish and your mom was Mormon, right? My mom was Mormon and my dad is Jewish. Yeah. So what, so what religion was, was forced upon you if any growing up and did you?
现在，当我们第二次巡演时，我，我只是对你的家庭和成长经历很着迷，因为其中有一些和我自己的经历有交叉，关于它是多么的搞砸了。但我记得你告诉我你妈妈，不，不，等等，你爸爸是，是犹太人，你妈妈是摩门教徒，对吧？我妈妈是摩门教徒，我爸爸是犹太人。是的。那么，那么什么宗教，是被强加给你的，如果有的话，在成长过程中，你有没有？
Well, not fucking Mormon because we all told my mom to take a long walk off of a long pier. And we didn't take that seriously. Once I realized I, we broke it down. I was the dominating person in that marriage and my mom was German. So she came over after the war. So we weren't about to take anything seriously that she said, you know what I mean? Right. He was Jewish and she was going to just shut up about being German for a long time until
嗯，不是该死的摩门教，因为我们都告诉妈妈去长码头走一走。我们没把那当回事。一旦我意识到我，我是那段婚姻中占主导地位的人，而我妈妈是德国人。所以她在战后过来。所以我们不会认真对待她说的任何话，你知道我的意思吗？对。他是犹太人，而她会很长一段时间对她是德国人这件事闭嘴，直到
things blew over from World War II. So we, did she marry him out of guilt? What happened? I think, I think maybe that had some, they had a quite a love affair. My parents, he met her in a ski store. He was buying ski socks and he saw her legs. Just the socks. No way.
二战的事情平息下来。所以我们，她是出于内疚才嫁给他的吗？发生了什么？我想，我想也许那有一点，他们有一段相当的恋情。我的父母，他在一家滑雪店遇见她。他在买滑雪袜，他看到了她的腿。只是袜子。不会吧。
Yeah, just the socks. He didn't ski either. He just went in there to buy a size 12 pair of socks or something like that, you know? Anyway, they had a love affair. My mother agreed to raise all her children Jewish. So I thought my mom was Jewish until my brother died. And then it was a big thing because, you know, in Judaism, Jews all have to be buried in a Jewish cemetery together. Right.
是的，只是袜子。他也不会滑雪。他只是进去买一双12码的袜子之类的，你知道吗？无论如何，他们有一段恋情。我母亲同意把她所有的孩子都抚养为犹太人。所以我以为我妈妈是犹太人，直到我哥哥去世。然后那成了一件大事，因为，你知道，在犹太教中，犹太人必须一起埋葬在犹太墓地。对。
And then they had to buy my like a plot of graves when my brother died and they wanted to buy one for both of my parents. And I remember our rabbi was at our house and he's like, Rita, my mother, isn't Jewish. She can't be buried in a Jewish cemetery. And I was like, that was the first I had heard of it. And I was like, what do you mean mom's not Jewish? What is mom? And, you know, I was nine. So nobody really took my feeling seriously or into account.
然后他们不得不买我的，像是一块墓地，当我哥哥去世时，他们想为我的父母双方各买一个。我记得我们的拉比在我们家，他说，Rita，我母亲，不是犹太人。她不能埋在犹太墓地。我当时就像，那是我第一次听说。我当时就像，什么意思妈妈不是犹太人？妈妈是什么？而且，你知道，我当时九岁。所以没人真正把我的感受当回事或考虑在内。
They just thought she doesn't really understand what's going on. And then when my mom did pass away, she never converted to Judaism. She was Mormon. Like she wore the undergarments. She had missionaries at our house all the time. Wow. And so when she did pass away, my dad was like, listen, we have to have, you know, we're having a Jewish funeral for your mother so that she can be buried next to your brother. And we're like, dad, this is such bullshit.
他们只是认为她不真正理解发生了什么。然后当我妈妈去世时，她从未皈依犹太教。她是摩门教徒。就像她穿着内衣。她家里一直有传教士。哇。所以当她去世时，我爸爸说，听着，我们必须有，你知道，我们要为你母亲举行犹太葬礼，这样她就可以埋在你哥哥旁边。我们当时说，爸爸，这真是胡扯。
Like all of her Mormon friends are coming to the funeral. Like they're all at our house. We can't do that. He's like, don't make eye contact with any of those people. Okay. We just have to get through the funeral and get her in the ground. And I was like, my family was so fucked up. We couldn't even get funerals, right? Oh my God.
就像她所有的摩门教朋友都要来参加葬礼。就像他们都在我们家。我们不能那样做。他说，不要和那些人有眼神接触。好的。我们只需要熬过葬礼，把她埋进土里。我当时就像，我的家庭太搞砸了。我们甚至连葬礼都搞不定？哦，天哪。
What a crazy world to imagine. Here is somebody. She's your mom. She's your dad's wife. Everybody loves her. Your dad has these feelings. He wants her to be buried next to her son. Like all this fucking like just it's all about love and love of people.
多么疯狂的世界。这是某个人。她是你的妈妈。她是你的爸爸的妻子。每个人都爱她。你的爸爸有这些感觉。他想让她埋在她儿子的旁边。就像所有这些该死的，就像这全是关于爱和对人的爱。
And there's fucking religion whether whichever one it is, take your pick. Sticking his fucking nose in and ruining the experience of people who are just fucking grieving and in love with each other. And that is such fucking bullshit. Like that is fucked. That is crazy. Yeah. Well, what's crazier is that he was naked in our kitchen a week later with his
还有该死的宗教，无论哪一个，随你挑。插手其中，毁掉了那些正在该死地悲伤并彼此相爱的人的体验。那真是该死的胡扯。就像那太搞砸了。那太疯狂了。是的。嗯，更疯狂的是，一周后他在我们的厨房里裸体，和他的
cleaning lady. So he obviously took my mom's death very hard. But his feet were warm. I'll bet. Right. Did he keep just the socks on? Yeah. Yeah.
清洁女工在一起。所以他显然非常沉重地接受了我妈妈的去世。但他的脚很暖和。我敢打赌。对。他只留着袜子吗？是的。是的。
He had a sock on. That's where he took your mom's death. Semi hard. Nice. The rumor was. The rumor was. Right into his socks. Now, did you, what about any of the Mormon stuff make its way into the house?
他穿着袜子。这就是他接受你妈妈去世的方式。半硬。不错。传言是。传言是。直接穿进他的袜子里。现在，你，关于任何摩门教的东西有没有进入家里？
Or was it more like if the father is a Mormon, then there's a lot of wives around and kids around. Or do you come from a big family? How dare you? First of all, how dare you? I'm not sure. I'm rusty on all this stuff. On Mormonism?
还是说更像是如果父亲是摩门教徒，那么周围有很多妻子和孩子。还是你来自一个大家庭？你怎么敢？首先，你怎么敢？我不确定。我对所有这些东西都很生疏。关于摩门教？
Yeah. Well, we actually lived in Salt Lake City for a while. So I do, I know it sort of kind of, but not, not really anyway. Yeah. It's kind of a adjacent to a lot of people. Like a lot of us, we kind of know a little bit. I remember I read the Book of Mormon. My mom, because my mom got religious after my brother died.
是的。嗯，我们实际上在盐湖城住过一段时间。所以我确实，我知道它某种程度上，但不是，不是真的，无论如何。是的。它对很多人来说有点邻近。就像我们很多人一样，我们多少知道一点。我记得我读过《摩门经》。我妈妈，因为我妈妈在我哥哥去世后变得虔诚了。
You know, everybody handles their grief like that. Like people get sick. They get religious. They get angry. They hide it away. My mom got really back involved with the church because before that she was just carrying on like a Jewish mother. Like at all of our Bat Mitzvahs and Bar Mitzvahs, my brothers and sisters, I'm one of six kids.
你知道，每个人都那样处理他们的悲伤。就像人们生病了。他们变得虔诚。他们变得愤怒。他们把它藏起来。我妈妈真的重新参与了教会，因为在那之前她只是像个犹太母亲一样继续生活。就像在我们所有的受戒礼和成人礼上，我的兄弟姐妹，我是六个孩子之一。
My mom would be on the Bema at, you know, at the temple singing Hebrew prayers. So when I found out she wasn't Jewish, I was like, wait, what? So it was very confusing. But my mom converted my one sister, Shoshana, she became Mormon too. She's now finally recovering from that. But I remember reading the Book of Mormon when I was like 11. How does the Mormon church even allow a Shoshana in there? Shoshana, it should be that way.
我妈妈会在会堂的讲台上，你知道，在寺庙里唱希伯来语祈祷文。所以当我发现她不是犹太人时，我当时就像，等等，什么？所以这非常令人困惑。但我妈妈让我一个姐妹皈依了，Shoshana，她也成了摩门教徒。她现在终于从中恢复过来了。但我记得我在11岁左右读过《摩门经》。摩门教会怎么允许Shoshana进去？Shoshana，应该是那样的。
He can't get through the door. They'll take anyone. Exactly. There's no prerequisites. Yeah. Charles, were your parents like, it's kind of a boring question, but I'm interested. Were your parents supportive in you going to comedy or the entertainment business at all? Were they like, what are you doing?
他进不了门。他们会接受任何人。完全正确。没有先决条件。是的。Charles，你的父母是否，这是一个有点无聊的问题，但我很感兴趣。你的父母是否支持你从事喜剧或娱乐行业？他们是否像，你在做什么？
I don't understand why you're going there. No. My parents, when I left, you don't understand the kind, I was a hell on wheels when I grew up. I was just, whatever anybody told me to do, I did the opposite and told them to fuck off, you know, teachers, any authority, like authority figures, both of my parents. So by the time I moved to LA, I think I was 19 years old when I came out to LA and they were just like, this is the right thing. You should go.
我不明白你为什么要往那儿去。不。我的父母，当我离开时，你不明白那种，我成长时简直是个麻烦精。我只是，无论任何人告诉我做什么，我都做相反的事，并告诉他们去死，你知道，老师，任何权威，就像权威人物，我的父母双方。所以当我搬到洛杉矶时，我想我19岁时来到洛杉矶，他们只是觉得，这是正确的事。你应该去。
Everyone was so over me and my family that they were happy I was leaving. I was telling the story the other day. My brother, I was driving cross country. My dad was a used car dealer. So he gave me this like Audi Quattro, this used Audi Quattro, which I knew was going to break down as soon as I got across country, if I even made it. And my brother being as protective, you know, protective, over protective said, why don't you, I met this bartender last night in a bar and he's wants to go across country too.
每个人都受够了我和我的家人，以至于他们很高兴我离开。我前几天在讲这个故事。我哥哥，我当时正开车横穿全国。我爸爸是个二手车经销商。所以他给了我这辆像奥迪Quattro，这辆二手奥迪Quattro，我知道一旦我横穿全国，它就会坏掉，如果我能成功的话。而我哥哥作为保护，你知道，保护，过度保护说，你为什么不，我昨晚在酒吧遇到这个调酒师，他也想横穿全国。
Why don't you drive with him across country? Smart. So you're not alone. Oh my God. And I was like, hmm. And he goes, it's safer that way, Chelsea. And I was like, yeah, but this isn't a great endorsement. I mean, you just met this guy last night at a bar.
你为什么不和他一起开车横穿全国？聪明。这样你就不是一个人了。哦，天哪。我当时就像，嗯。他说，那样更安全，切尔西。我当时就像，是的，但这并不是一个很好的背书。我的意思是，你昨晚才在酒吧遇到这个家伙。
Yeah. But of course I was like, sure. So I pick up the guy. I don't know. His name was Andy Dick. Andy Dick. Yeah, it was Andy Dick, actually. It was David Spade and Andy Dick.
是的。但我当然就像，好的。所以我接上了那个家伙。我不知道。他的名字叫Andy Dick。Andy Dick。是的，其实是Andy Dick。是David Spade和Andy Dick。
He was two guys. The guy was two guys. It was twins. I was like, are you guys, oh my God. He said one guy and they just started multiplying. And the guy says to me, he goes, hey, do you want to go get some Coke in the city for the trip? And I was 19.
他是两个人。那个家伙是两个人。是双胞胎。我当时就像，你们是，哦，天哪。他说一个人，他们就开始繁殖了。那个家伙对我说，他说，嘿，你想去城里买点可卡因带在路上吗？我当时19岁。
And this was before I had discovered. Wait, was it Bateman? Was it Bateman that you picked up? It was. And I do like Bateman's cocaine stories, but it wasn't him. Guys, let her do the big reveal. All right. You're jumping ahead.
这是在我发现之前。等等，是Bateman吗？是你接上的Bateman吗？是的。我确实喜欢Bateman的可卡因故事，但不是他。伙计们，让她揭晓大谜底。好的。你跳得太快了。
And the guy goes, let's get some Coke. And I was like, all right. So we drive into New York City. He picks up his Coke, right? We're in the car. I don't even know if I had ever done cocaine at this point in my life. And we get in the car and we're driving. It's like a five hour drive.
那个家伙说，让我们买点可卡因。我当时就像，好的。所以我们开车进纽约市。他买了可卡因，对吧？我们在车里。我甚至不知道我当时是否在生活中做过可卡因。我们上了车，我们在开车。大约是五个小时的车程。
We left from New Jersey. And I think we ended up somewhere in Maryland because we were heading down south to go down that whatever route it is. And we get to a hotel room. We get two beds and we check in and he starts doing the Coke. And I was like, really the first night I was like, how's this going to work? And then he got maps out. This was before our cell phones.
我们从新泽西出发。我想我们最终到了马里兰州的某个地方，因为我们正往南走，走那条无论什么路线。我们到了一个酒店房间。我们有两张床，我们办理了入住，他开始做可卡因。我当时就像，真的第一晚我当时就像，这怎么行得通？然后他拿出了地图。这是在我们手机之前。
He got maps out and was laying them all across the room while he was snorting Coke and trying to figure out different routes that we could take. And I was like, oh, my fucking God. Sounds like a great night. He should have laid down the Coke in the route. Happening. And it was so annoying. And he wouldn't shut up.
他拿出地图，把它们铺满整个房间，同时他吸着可卡因，试图找出我们可以走的不同的路线。我当时就像，哦，我的天哪。听起来是个很棒的夜晚。他应该把可卡因铺在路线上。发生了。这太烦人了。他就是不停地说啊说。我说，伙计，你得停止说话。我得睡觉。我在开车。显然你永远无法再开车了，因为我们房间里有一磅可卡因。然后我当时就像，如果他在我值班时死了怎么办？不，他会先试着吻你。
He just kept talking and talking. I go, dude, you got to stop talking. I have to sleep. I'm driving. Clearly you're never going to be able to drive again because there's a pound of cocaine in our room. And then I was like, what if he dies on my watch? No, you're going to try to kiss you first.
他当时试着吻你了吗？是的，当然。是的。我去睡觉。他在我里面。是的。我去睡觉。但那并不难。
Did he try to kiss you then? Yeah, of course. Yeah. I go to sleep. He's inside of me. Yeah. I go to sleep. But it wasn't hard though.
我醒来，他还在从前一天晚上开始用地图。他说，我想我们可以走这边。我想我们可以走这边。我当时就像，这不可能发生。所以我拿上我的手提箱。我说，嘿，我想去把我们的东西放进车里。我拿上我们两个的手提箱。我把他的放在我们房间外面。
I wake up and he's still up from the night before with the maps. And he's like, I think we could go this way. I think we could go this way. And I was like, there's no way this is happening. So I take my suitcase. I go, hey, I want to go put our stuff in the car. I take both of our suitcases. I leave his right outside our room.
我拿上我的。我把它放进后备箱，我就直接开出了我们所在的那个马里兰酒店，独自开车走完了剩下的横穿全国的路，把他留在了五个小时路程之外。我再次从他那里听说。我哥哥当时就像，一旦我到了加利福尼亚，我当时就像，谢谢你那个白痴。他说，我听说你把他留在了马里兰。我当时就像，是的，我留下了。他说，是的，他不得不一路打车回去。
And I take mine. I put it in the trunk and I just pulled out of that like Maryland hotel that we were in and drove the rest of the way across country by myself and left him about five hours out. I overhear from him again. My brother was like, once I got to California, I was like, thanks a lot for that idiot. And he goes, I heard you left him in Maryland. I was like, yeah, I did. And he said, yeah, he had to take a taxi all the way back.
他说那是2000美元。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，还在告诉出租车司机去哪里以及哪条路线最好。真是个该死的……是的，那个出租车司机，可能是，是的，那个出租车司机当时就像，其实是500美元，直到你开始说话。所以现在是2000美元。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。
He said it was $2,000. By the way, by the way, telling the taxi driver where to go and which route is best still. What a fucking... Yeah, that taxi driver, it was probably, yeah, that taxi driver was like, actually it was $500 until you started talking. So now it's $2,000. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
所以当你到了洛杉矶，你19岁。是的，你开进去，你在该死的高速公路上。你去哪儿？第一站是什么？你想做什么？我只是想让人听到。我只是觉得我有强烈的观点，我认为我有很多错位的自信，我相信人们会从听到我要说的话中受益。
So when you got out to LA, you're 19 years old. Yeah, you pull in, you're on the fucking freeway. Where do you go? What's the first stop? What would you want to do? I just wanted people to hear. I just felt like I had strong opinions and I thought I had a lot of misplaced confidence and I believed that people would benefit from hearing what I had to say.
就像我真的相信我自己的想法是有价值的，并且我会在某种程度上做出贡献。我想我只是渴望关注，说实话。基本上就是这样。但我想要把它变成更复杂一点的东西。然后我和我的姑姑和叔叔住在一起，他们住在Beverly Glen。他们有九个孩子，我成了他们的保姆。我每天早上开着一辆小型货车送这些孩子上学，同时听Stern。我只是开始在餐馆打工。
Like I really believed that my own thoughts were valuable and that I was going to make a contribution in some way. I think I was just thirsty for the attention, to be honest. That's just basically what it was. But I wanted to make it into something a little bit more sophisticated. And then I lived with my aunt and uncle who lived on Beverly Glen. They had nine children and I became their kind of nanny. And I would drive these kids to school every morning in a minivan while I was listening to Stern. And I just started waiting tables.
然后我当时就像，好的，我在这里到底要做什么？就像我怎么才能被发现？就像我只是假设有人会看到我并说，哦，好的，跟我们来。什么是第一？你只是，你去喜剧商店了吗？你去即兴表演了吗？你找了经纪人吗？什么是第一？嗯，我去，我在21岁时酒驾了。不寻常的路线开始。不寻常。
And then I was like, all right, what the fuck am I going to do out here? Like how am I going to get discovered? Like I just assumed somebody would see me and be like, oh, okay, come with us. And what was first? Did you just, did you go to the comedy store? Did you go to the improv? Did you like get an agent? What was first? Well, I went to, I got a DUI when I was 21 years old. Unusual route start. Unusual.
是的，不寻常且出乎意料，坦率地说。我想指出，从那以后我再也没有过，因为我喜欢第一次就吸取教训，让它成为最后一次。但无论如何，我酒驾了，我不得不去参加酒驾课程，这基本上是他们把你放进去的一个系统，他们教你如何避免下一次酒驾。所以他们告诉你，比如如果你被拦下，你一说你喝了点酒，你就完了。就像你总是必须说不，否认，否认，否认。我当时就像，等等，这是什么课？你基本上只是在教我们如何避免再次被捕，而且是由国家买单。然后每个人都必须站起来讲述他们的酒驾故事。
Yes, unusual and unexpected, quite frankly. And I'd like to note that I have never had one since because I like to learn my lesson the first time and make it the last time. But anyway, I got my DUI and I had to go to DUI classes, which is basically a system that they put you in where they teach you how to get out of your next DUI. So they tell you, like if you get pulled over the minute you say you've had something to drink, you're screwed. Like you always have to say no, deny, deny, deny. And I was like, wait, what is this class? You're just basically teaching us how to avoid getting arrested again and it's being paid for by the state. And then everyone had to get up and tell their DUI story.
所以我非常，非常害怕，因为我不喜欢公开演讲，我不知道。所以我每周都会躲在教室后面，就像别该死地挑我。我不知道我要说什么。我不知道我的故事是什么。在最后一节课上，他没人了，我不得不站起来，我记得就像，你知道，当你非常紧张时，你的腿在发抖。我当时就像，哦，天哪。我站起来，开始讲述我的故事，每个人都开始大笑，因为就像我称警察是种族主义者。我们都是白人，你知道，我做的一切。我在Civil Brand县监狱待了大约24小时，因为他们无法让我离开系统，直到他们让我进入系统。而我在这里，这个，你知道，白人，有权势的小泽西犹太女孩，当时就像，什么？
And so I was really, really scared because I didn't like public speaking and I didn't know. So I would just kind of hide in the back of the class every week, like don't fucking pick on me. I don't know what I'm going to say. I don't know what my story is. And on the very last class, he was out of people and I had to get up and I remember just like, you know, when you're so nervous, your leg is shaking. And I just was like, oh my God. And I got up there and I started telling my story and everyone just started laughing and laughing because like I called the cop racist. We were both white, you know, everything I did. I was in civil brand county jail for like 24 hours because they couldn't get me out of the system until they got me into the system. And here I am, this, you know, white, entitled little Jersey Jewish girl who was like, what?
Civil Brand。我只是找到了我能找到的最大的，最胖的黑人女性。我当时就像，我们做朋友吧。在那之后，在我说话并做了那个之后，人们说，你应该做单口喜剧。然后我想，哦，那是个好主意。我应该做单口喜剧。你知道，你独自在舞台上拿着麦克风正是你所追求的。所以那就是我开始做单口喜剧的时候。所以我确实把那个酒驾课程归功于给了我这个想法，因为人们，如果人们没对我那样说，我不知道我会不会想到自己去做单口喜剧。有趣的是它在里面。在你站起来之前它就在里面。你只是，你只是需要某种东西把它从你身上拉出来。是的。
Civil brand. I just found the biggest, fattest black woman I could find. And I was like, let's be friends. And after that, after I spoke and I did that, people were like, you should do stand up. And then I thought, oh, that's a great idea. I should do stand up. You know, you on stage alone with a microphone is exactly what you're after. So that's when I started doing stand up. So I do credit that DUI class with giving me the idea because people, if people hadn't said that to me, I don't know that I would have thought about doing stand up on my own. It's interesting that it was in there. It was in there before you got up there. You just didn't, you just needed some kind of something to pull it out of you. Yeah.
是的，一个小出口把它从我身上拉出来。你有没有想过追踪那个逮捕你的警察并感谢他的职业生涯？不，我没想过那个。我当时在等，我其实在等你去那样做，Will。那是你觉得舒服的事情吗？我当然做。当然。所以，Charles，你知道，看起来在过去十年左右，你已经，你已经从你令人难以置信的搞笑单口喜剧，到电视节目，你知道，你的幽默来自从观察喜剧到朋友和家人，介于两者之间的一切。但后来发生了一个转变，你进入了某种更政治和世界性的问题，这对你很重要，你仍然对此感到热情。那对你来说的转折点是什么？有一个事件或什么东西，你知道，稍微改变了你的焦点吗？
Yeah, a little outlet to pull it out of me. Did you ever think about tracking down that police officer who busted you and thanking him for your career? No, I haven't thought about that. I was waiting for, I was actually going to wait for you to do that, Will. Is that something you feel comfortable doing? Of course I do. Of course. So, Charles, you know, it seems like in like the last decade or so, you've been, you've gone from your unbelievably hilarious stand up to and television shows where, you know, your humor comes out of everything from like observational comedy to friends and family, everything in between. But then a shift happened where you got into kind of more political and world issues and that mattered to you and that you still feel passionate about. And what was that turning point for you? Was there an event or something that, that, you know, shifted your focus a little bit?
是的，它叫选举，Sean，2016年的。不，我不知道它是否在那之前。我不知道它是否在那之前。不，我的意思是，那真的让我到了一个地方，我只是想，哦，天哪，美国要完了。是的。就像我们过时了。那就是你的书，那就是你写书的时候。是的，所以那是，我经历了一段非常困难的时期，是在，就在我的Netflix节目结束时，我，那就是我开始治疗的时候，我当时非常，就像，你知道，他们说你的愤怒，一切都为你服务，直到它不再服务，对吧？是的。
Yeah, it was called the election, Sean, of 2016. No, I didn't know if it was before that. I didn't know if it was before that. No, I mean, that just really got me to a place where I just thought, oh God, America's going to be over. Yeah. Like we're a passe. And that's when your book, and that's when you wrote your book. And yeah, so that was like, I went through a really difficult time was after, right, as my Netflix show was ending and I, that's when I got into therapy and I was just so it's like, you know, they say your anger, everything works for you until it doesn't, right? Yeah.
而那基本上是我所有事情都达到顶峰的时候，我当时在情感上只是，哦，我需要在这里得到一些帮助。就像我不再做得很好。而以前为我服务的东西现在不再为我服务了。所以那里面有一个巨大的转变，我变得非常政治化，你知道，人们对此感到非常恼火。而我当时是，但我感觉我必须，我只是不能对此保持安静。我只是不能。就像，如果你不说点什么，那这对你意味着什么？而我，而我不那样，你知道，我有时希望我能闭嘴。
And that was kind of when everything came to a head for me where I was emotionally just like, oh, I need to get some help here. Like I'm not doing great anymore. And what was working for me before isn't working for me now. So there was a big shift in that and I got really political, you know, and people got really annoyed by that. And I was, but I felt like I had to, I just couldn't be quiet about that. I just couldn't. It's like, if you don't say something, then what does that say about you? And I, and I'm not like that, you know, I wish I could shut up sometimes.
而在那之前，你并没有，我不知道，我不想把话塞进你嘴里，但就像对政治合拍，或者你没有以那种方式受到它们的影响。这，这公平吗？不，我对政治合拍。是合拍，不是调谐。我受到了它的影响。也许你稍后可以过来。我知道，我总是不得不纠正你。是的，不，我喜欢它。
And before that, you weren't just as, I don't know, I don't want to put words in your mouth, but like in tune to politics or you weren't as affected by them in that way. Is that, is that fair? No, I was attuned to politics. It's attuned to not in tune. And I was affected by it. Maybe you can come over later. I know, I always have to correct you. Yeah, no, I love it.
但我当时是，它进行得很顺利。我们有Barack Obama，我以为事情正在改变。我，在我天真的，你知道，小泡沫里，我当时就像，哦，世界是个伟大的地方。看看美国在繁荣。所以我没有那么激烈和，和大声，你知道，直到，直到那个。你觉得那个，你，你是否满足或平息了你所做的事情正在产生一些改变？还是仅仅能够说出你的想法就足够了？如果从中产生任何好的东西，那就太好了。
But I was, it was going well. We had Barack Obama and I thought things were changing. I, in my naive, you know, little bubble, I'm like, oh, the world's a great place. Look at America thriving. So I wasn't as vehement and, and loud, you know, until, until that. Did you feel that, did you, were you, were you satisfied or pacified that what you were doing was affecting some change? Or was it just enough to sort of just be able to speak your mind? And if anything good comes from it, then great.
但在此之前，至少我在说出我的想法。是的，嗯，我做了很多事情。比如我进行了一次横穿全国的巡演，去大学和校园，去，你知道，辩论保守派，谈论选举，去理解为什么人们那样做。我为这么多候选人努力工作，以至于我最终在期中选举中当选。所以你确实觉得当你可以看到像一个有形的事件，你知道，或者具体的证据，我应该说，你的努力，而不仅仅是我的，是富有成效的。显然，数以百万计的人在做和我一样的事情。所以是的，感觉非常好。参与那个过程感觉很好。
But until then, at least I'm speaking my mind. Yeah, well, I did a lot of stuff. Like I went on a tour across country to colleges and campuses to, to, you know, debate conservatives to talk about the election to understand why people did that. And I worked really hard for so many candidates that I ended up getting elected in the midterm. So you do feel like it is fruitful when you can see like a tangible event, you know, or concrete evidence, I should say, of, of your efforts and not just mine. Obviously, millions of people were doing the same thing as I was. So yeah, it felt really good. It felt good to be involved in that process.
感觉很充实，你知道，就像我生活中的一切，我做一切都像150%。然后，你知道，我当时就像，好的，我做完了这个，你知道，然后我们有了这个总统，我们在处理这些狗屎。你只是，哦，天哪，这种循环永无止境。所以我过去几周停止看报纸了，因为它确实让你负担沉重，升高你的血压，而你想成为一个有效的。欢迎来到俱乐部。是的，我是认真的。我是认真的。不，不，不，这些家伙知道我一直谈论它，我大约一年半前，我在我的DVR上关掉了所有的有线新闻。
It felt full on, you know, and just like everything in my life, I do everything like 150%. And then, you know, I'm like, okay, I'm done with this, you know, and then we get this president and we're dealing with this shit. And you're just like, oh my God, it's never ending this kind of cycle. So I've stopped reading the paper for the last couple of weeks because it's just, it really does tax you and raises your blood pressure and you want to be an effective. Welcome to the club. Yeah, I'm serious. I'm serious. No, no, no, these guys know I talk about it all the time that I about a year and a half ago, I turned off all the cable news things in my DVR.
我再也受不了了，因为我当时就像，嗯，最终你，首先，并不是说你不会发现正在发生的事情。在我们生活的世界里，这几乎是不可能的。我不需要被24小时7天提醒，我也不需要让它影响我到我觉得，我得用“有毒”这个词，就像有毒。它感觉就像它在任何时候都渗透到你的整个存在。是的，这很扫兴。这很扫兴。我们马上回来。抱歉。
I can't take it anymore because I was like, well, ultimately you're, first of all, it's not like you're not going to find out about the stuff that's going on. It's virtually impossible in the world that we live in. And I don't need to be reminded of a 24 seven and I don't need to have it affect me to the point where I feel, I gotta hit the word toxic, like toxic. Where it's just like, it feels like it sort of permeates your entire being at all times. Yeah, it's a bummer. It's a big bummer. We'll be right back. I'm sorry.
让我们，让我们换个话题。我们开始吧。准备好，看着这个。Sean，你让我们走上了这条毁灭之路。我知道。你把它毁了。她正在进行喜剧巡演，看在上帝的份上。让我们回到宗教。
Let's, let's change the subject. Here we go. Ready, watch this. Sean, you set us on this path of destruction. I know. And you've ruined it. She's doing a comedy tour for fuck's sake. Let's get back to religion.
不，我们会回到宗教。不，我们停在了热点。赌博怎么样？赌博。让我们谈谈小狗怎么样？动物怎么样？你喜欢动物，对吧？让我们谈谈一些动物。
No, we'll get back to religion. No, we stopped with the hot. What about gambling? Gambling. Let's talk about what about puppies? How about animals? You love animals, right? Let's talk about some animals.
哦，我的动物不尊重我。你们在COVID期间第一次和我家人在一起。我当时就像，去死吧。我的狗认为我是，它们认为我的管家是它们的救星，它们对待我就像我是它们的监护人。它们是，这，这太深了，在COVID期间第一次和我的狗单独在一起真是令人沮丧。我去了惠斯勒。我去滑雪，因为我喜欢滑雪，我想，嗯，我不会在洛杉矶我的房子里待四个月。我会去惠斯勒。
Oh, my animals do not respect me. You guys alone with my family for the first time during COVID. I was like, fuck this. My dogs think that I'm, they think my housekeeper is their rescuer and they treat me like I'm their conservator. They are, it was, it was so deep, demoralizing being alone with my dogs for the first time during COVID. And I went to whistler. I went skiing because I love to ski and I thought, well, I'm not going to spend four months in LA in my house. I'll go to whistler.
我第一次独自带着我的狗。它们会看着我的眼睛，只是到处撒尿，你知道，在我们的地方。是的，我知道。看着我的眼睛。就像，你该死的，你在开玩笑吗，你以为你要照顾我们？对。我会带它们去，我在惠斯勒的第一天带它们去散步。我在这个小私人社区，对吧？
And I had my dogs for the first time alone with me. They would just look me in the eye and just spot piss, you know, in our place. Yeah, I know it. Look me in the eye. Like, are you fucking, are you kidding me that you think you're going to look after us? Right. I would take them for, I took them for a walk the first day I'm in whistler. I'm in this little private neighborhood, right?
我可能是我得到它们以来第一次带我的狗去散步。让我们诚实点。因为我不得不独自去惠斯勒，你知道，那是COVID。你可能，没人能进去。而且，而且所以我带着它们散步，它们的兄弟姐妹松狮犬，它们是同一窝的，它们是救援犬。我想把它放进去，这样Peter就不会该死地把我顶上去。我过去和它们有过问题。当然。
And I'm taking my dogs for a walk probably for the first time since I got them. Let's be honest. And because I had to go to whistler alone, you know, it was COVID. You could, nobody could get in. And, and so I'm walking them and their, their brother sister chow chows, they're from the same litter and their rescues. I want to put that in there just so Peter doesn't fucking bump me up. I've had problems with them in the past. Sure.
我正带着我的狗去散步，这大概是我养它们以来的第一次，说实话。因为我不得不独自去惠斯勒，你知道，当时是新冠疫情期间，没人能进去。所以我带着它们散步，它们是亲兄妹，松狮犬，是同一窝出生的，而且是我救助回来的。我得把这点加上，免得彼得又来找我麻烦。我过去在它们身上遇到过一些问题，确实如此。
So I took them for a walk one morning and this woman, and I didn't have them on leashes because my dogs are so lazy. They can't even run, you know, they're just like, and I'm walking around the corner and this woman sees them. She goes, oh, and I'm like, really? There's no leashes. You don't have leashes on the dogs. And I said, they're not aggressive. Like, okay, I'll get the leashes, but they're not going to do anything. And she's like, it's not for me. It's not for me. I mean, somebody might see them and think they're bears. And they're like, they're like one feet tall.
有一天早上我带它们去散步，我没给它们拴狗绳，因为我的狗太懒了。它们甚至跑不动，你知道，它们就是那样。我走到拐角处，有个女人看到了它们。她说，噢，我说，真的吗？没拴绳子。你没给狗拴绳子。我说，它们不凶。我说，好吧，我会去拿绳子，但它们不会做什么的。她说，不是为了我。不是为了我。我是说，别人看到它们可能会以为是熊。而它们只有一英尺高。
They're both wearing handkerchiefs. So nobody's going to think that. But yeah, my dogs, after I took them from home from whistler, I just my, my cleaning lady was like, when I came home, I realized like, I just, that was abusive to take them with me because I don't have the same level of attention to them that she does. You know, I, I don't know if she has peanut butter in her underwear or what she's up to. But those dogs, when they're with her, they thrive. And when with, with me, it feels like they're going to crossover. I'm going to put jelly in mine and just come over and we're going to be a family.
它们都戴着手帕。所以没人会那么想。但是，是的，我的狗，我把它们从惠斯勒带回家后，我的清洁工说，当我回家时，我意识到，带它们一起去简直是在虐待它们，因为我没有她对它们那种程度的关注。你知道，我不知道她是不是在内衣里藏了花生酱还是在干什么。但那些狗和她在一起时，它们长得很好。而和我在一起时，感觉它们快要挂了。我要在我的内衣里放点果冻，然后过去，我们就能成为一家人了。
That doesn't work for dogs, honey. Unless you have a, maybe a cat. Do you have a cat? Oh, you do have a cat. No, Scottie's a cat. You should. All right. So listen, Charles, you know, you go ahead, Sean. You got another question.
亲爱的，那招对狗没用。除非你有一只，也许是一只猫。你有猫吗？噢，你确实有猫。不，斯科蒂是只猫。你应该。好吧。听着，查尔斯，你知道，你继续吧，肖恩。你还有个问题。
Fuck it. Yeah. Don't let anybody else chime in here. Oh my God. Go ahead. I've talked on this podcast and we started. I know. By the way, I've listened to this podcast, Sean, and this is the most you've spoken. Because I get excited when I see you.
去他的。是的。别让其他人插嘴。天哪。继续。我在这播客上说了很多，我们刚开始。我知道。顺便说一句，肖恩，我听过这个播客，这是你说话最多的一次。因为看到你我很兴奋。
Jason's on his only fans page. Look at Jason down there. He wishes he knew what that was. Are you kidding? What is only fans? There you go. What is only an event? Truly.
杰森在他的OnlyFans页面上。看那边的杰森。他希望他知道那是什么。你在开玩笑吗？什么是OnlyFans？就是这样。什么是OnlyFans？真的。
Is that a, is that a thing? Yeah, it is a thing. You'll find out about it soon enough. Now that you've heard it once, you'll hear it again. Unbelievable. Charles, I heard you on your, by the way, you have a fantastic podcast. I love it. You're so funny.
那是，那是真的吗？是的，是真的。你很快就会知道了。既然你听过一次，你还会再听到的。难以置信。查尔斯，顺便说一句，我在你的节目里听过你，你的播客太棒了。我很喜欢。你太搞笑了。
And you on it, you said, you were talking about something about funerals. Like, I can't remember if it's getting hit on at a funeral or not. Did you say it was okay to get hit on a funeral? It's not okay to get hit. No, it's not okay. I mean, it's not appropriate. And if, and even if you liked a man or were into him and wanted to have sex with him, if he did that at a funeral, it's so not hot that you can never do that.
你在节目里说，你在谈论关于葬礼的事情。就像，我不记得是不是在葬礼上被搭讪了。你说在葬礼上被搭讪是可以的吗？在葬礼上被搭讪是不对的。不，那不对。我是说，那不合适。而且即使你喜欢一个男人，或者对他有意思，想和他发生关系，如果他在葬礼上那样做，那一点也不性感，你永远不能那样做。
What about your crying? You need a shoulder to cry on. Has that happened to you? Has somebody hit on you at a funeral? What if it's open casket? No, but I heard a story recently about two very famous people at a funeral making out at a funeral at my friend. Yes.
那哭泣呢？你需要一个可以依靠的肩膀。这发生在你身上过吗？有人在葬礼上搭讪过你吗？如果是开棺瞻仰怎么办？不，但我最近听到一个故事，关于两个非常有名的人在葬礼上亲热，在我朋友的葬礼上。是的。
And she told me that they were on top of each other at a memorial service. Oh my God. Making out like tongue kissing. And I'm like, you fucking have to be kidding me. It's so disrespectful. Well, it was at the, it was at the wake. It wasn't at the ceremony, right? No, it was at a memorial, but still, it's still whatever.
她告诉我，他们在追悼会上搂在一起。天哪。像舌吻那样亲热。我说，你他妈一定是在开玩笑。这太不尊重人了。好吧，那是在守灵的时候。不是在仪式上，对吧？不，那是在追悼会上，但还是，不管怎样。
It's still memorial and it's still fucking hot as, or really rude. Interesting. But depends. Were they good looking people? Yeah. It depends. Yeah, they're both good looking people. They're fucking great.
那还是追悼会，而且还是他妈的性感，或者真的很粗鲁。有趣。但看情况。他们是好看的人吗？是的。看情况。是的，他们都是好看的人。他们太棒了。
I mean, watching good looking people make out, I don't care where you are. In front of a casket. That's going to, that. Right. And they're celebrities, so they should be able to do whatever they want anyway. Celebrities. Let them do what they want. They're just like us, but they're not.
我是说，看好看的人亲热，我不在乎你在哪。在棺材前。那会，那。对。而且他们是名人，所以无论如何他们应该能做任何他们想做的事。名人。让他们做他们想做的事。他们就像我们一样，但他们不是。
I wonder if anybody got a stiff. Get it? Hey, Chels, let me ask you something else. You know, for the, Oh my God, Sean, Sean, we got to pause there for a second. Hold on a second. Where's Scotty? Sean, where's Scotty?
我想知道有没有人硬了。懂了吗？嘿，切尔斯，让我问你点别的。你知道，为了，天哪，肖恩，肖恩，我们得暂停一下。等一下。斯科蒂在哪？肖恩，斯科蒂在哪？
I hope those doors behind you burst open and somebody comes with piano wire and strangles you right now. Just fucking, that's it. Fucking Sean's. Okay, wait. You can take this microphone wire, Sean, and just do it. I'll do it myself. No, Chels.
我希望你身后的那些门突然打开，有人拿着钢琴线现在就把你勒死。去他的，就是这样。去他的肖恩。好吧，等等。你可以拿这根麦克风线，肖恩，直接动手吧。我自己来。不，切尔斯。
I wanted to know for real though, because for, for the time that I've known you, you seem like you're always, always, always on the go, go, go, go, go, go nonstop. Who is your constant when you come back home or, or, you know, that you hear this word a lot, like camp Chelsea. Who's in your camp or who are your constant people that you come back to all the time that you're like, now I'm home. My family is like that. My family and I are pretty tight.
不过我真的想知道，因为在我认识你的这段时间里，你看起来总是，总是，总是忙个不停，不停地走。当你回家时，谁是你的依靠，或者，你知道，你经常听到这个词，比如“切尔西阵营”。谁在你的阵营里，或者谁是你一直回到身边的那些人，让你觉得，现在我回家了。我的家人就是那样。我和我的家人关系很紧密。
So we're, we spend a lot of time together. We go on vacations a lot together. That's good. There are a lot of them in New Jersey, but, you know, not my dogs, obviously. And my family is pretty much my constant. I mean, my friends, you know, I have different groups of friends and lots of friends and LA has been my home base for a long time, but I, I don't ever spend a long duration of time in LA.
所以我们，我们花很多时间在一起。我们经常一起去度假。那很好。他们在纽泽西有很多，但是，你知道，显然不是我的狗。我的家人基本上就是我的依靠。我是说，我的朋友，你知道，我有不同的朋友圈，有很多朋友，洛杉矶长期以来一直是我的大本营，但我，我从来不在洛杉矶待很长时间。
I go in and out. Actually COVID was the longest amount of time I ever spent in LA. And my sister invaded my house with her three adult children because apparently parenting never fucking ends. And I have, you know, designed my life in a way that I didn't ever want to have children living in my house. So she came down for COVID for three months with her three adult children, 24, 21 and 18. And they stayed for three months.
我进进出出。其实新冠疫情是我在洛杉矶待过的最长时间。我姐姐带着她三个成年孩子入侵了我的房子，因为显然育儿永远他妈的没完没了。我，你知道，设计我的生活方式时，我从来不想让孩子住在我的房子里。所以她因为新冠疫情带着她三个成年孩子（24岁、21岁和18岁）住了三个月。他们待了三个月。
And then I put the house on the market and sold it. So that would never happen to me again. Are you serious? How did you let that happen? I, well, it was my sister. So obviously I can't say no to family, but, and I thought, oh, this will be fun. I had, you know, the room, I have this great fun house. And so they all came down.
然后我把房子挂牌卖了。这样我就再也不会遇到这种情况了。你是认真的吗？你怎么能让这种事发生？我，好吧，那是我姐姐。所以显然我不能拒绝家人，但是，我想，噢，这会很有趣。我有，你知道，空间，我有这栋很棒的房子。所以他们都来了。
And then all of a sudden I was doing dinners every night at 730 with, you know, three kids and every night somebody would cry. And, and then one, oh, and then my nephew, who my nephew, he's 24 years old. He's a sports journalist and he was, he was getting really frustrated during COVID. You know, he's like, I can't date. I'm like, date buddy. Like people are dying. We're in a global pandemic.
然后突然间，我每天晚上7点半都要做晚餐，你知道，带着三个孩子，而且每天晚上都有人哭。然后一个，噢，然后我的侄子，我的侄子，他24岁。他是个体育记者，他在新冠疫情期间变得非常沮丧。你知道，他说，我没法约会。我说，约会吧伙计。人们正在死去。我们正处于全球大流行中。
Yeah. So one night I go, do you know any funerals I could go to to pick up some chicks? Wait till somebody else dies in our family. We can hook you up. So he had an outdoor, like an outdoor date in my backyard and my sister goes, let me get you out of the house. You're getting really irritated with everybody. And I was like, okay, let's, so we went for drinks at a friend's house, probably Mary's.
是的。所以有一天晚上我说，你知道有什么葬礼我可以去搭讪妹子吗？等我们家里再死个人吧。我们可以帮你介绍。所以他在我的后院进行了一次户外约会，我姐姐说，让我带你离开这房子吧。你对每个人都感到很烦躁。我说，好吧，走吧，所以我们去朋友家喝了点酒，可能是玛丽家。
And we came back and he was at my kitchen counter, my, my 24 year old nephew, my first born nephew. Okay. And he is acting like Ernest Hemingway, just sitting at, you know, just, you know, really buzzed and really frustrated running his hands through his hair. Like he'd never been through so much. And I was like, Jake, did you get, you know, did you get some penetration? What happened?
我们回来时，他正在我的厨房台面上，我24岁的侄子，我的长侄子。好吧。他表现得像海明威一样，就坐在那，你知道，喝得醉醺醺的，非常沮丧，用手抓着头发。好像他从来没经历过这么多事。我说，杰克，你，你知道，你得到什么深入交流了吗？发生了什么？
I was like, no Chelsea, of course I did it. And it's not funny. He's all backed up. And I looked at him and I was like, no fucking way. Am I listening? I'm like, is this boy frustrated because he's horny? And I couldn't believe it. So I walked upstairs to my bedroom and my sister came up an hour later.
我说，不，切尔西，我当然做了。这不好笑。他憋坏了。我看着他，我说，没门。我在听吗？我说，这男孩是因为发情而沮丧吗？我简直不敢相信。所以我走上楼回到卧室，我姐姐一小时后上来了。
She's like, sorry about that. I go, oh, sorry about that. Your job is to listen to your son talk about how sexually frustrated he is in the middle of this pandemic. Do you know, I'm horny too, but I can't fuck anybody because you guys won't get the fuck out of my house. So anyway, they left after that. I would have come over.
她说，抱歉。我说，噢，抱歉。你的工作是听你儿子谈论他在疫情期间性欲有多么沮丧吗？你知道，我也发情，但我不能和任何人做爱，因为你们这些家伙不滚出我的房子。总之，他们在那之后就离开了。我会过来的。
Sean, you've always been an amazing lover. I love having sex with you, Sean. He doesn't. I mean, I mean, especially when you can't shut the fuck up while we're having sex, you know, you just drill me with one question after another. I don't drill you with my penis. Just questions. No, you drill me with questions.
肖恩，你一直是个很棒的情人。我喜欢和你做爱，肖恩。他不喜欢。我是说，我是说，特别是在我们做爱时你不能闭上你那张臭嘴的时候，你知道，你一个接一个地问我问题。我没有用我的阴茎钻你。只是问题。不，你用问题钻我。
And now back to the show. Chelsea, you are in the middle of your tour or the beginning of it or the end? I'm in the beginning of it. I announced 30 dates and I am announcing 30 more. So I'm going to be on tour for the next year. So it's pretty fun. And we kicked it off at the Santa Barbara Bowl. I opened the Santa Barbara Bowl after two years.
现在回到节目。切尔西，你是在巡演的中途，还是开始，还是结束？我在开始阶段。我宣布了30场日期，我还要宣布30场。所以我明年都要巡演。所以这很有趣。我们在圣巴巴拉碗开启了巡演。我在两年后重新开放了圣巴巴拉碗。
It was closed. So that was epic. It was the night of the full blue moon. So it was just such a great vibe. My friends came. I love that. And yeah, it's fun to be on tour. It's fun to be a reason people are coming back together for the first time and big groups.
它关闭了。所以那很史诗。那是满月之夜。所以气氛太棒了。我的朋友们来了。我喜欢那样。是的，巡演很有趣。成为人们第一次在大群体中重新聚在一起的理由很有趣。
And, and, you know, my crowds are safe and they're vaccinated. So I have, you know, faith in that. And yeah, I'm just loving doing standup again. You know, I want to get back to like, did you have it? Sorry, did you have a chance to work on your material, even though there weren't a lot of places that were open during COVID? Yeah, yeah, I had a, I mean, I have been, I've been not, yeah, getting up for the last two months, putting my new hour together.
而且，你知道，我的观众很安全，他们都接种了疫苗。所以我对那有信心。是的，我只是喜欢再次做单口喜剧。你知道，我想回到，你有机会打磨你的素材吗，即使在新冠疫情期间没有很多地方开放？是的，是的，我有，我是说，我一直，我一直没有，是的，过去两个月一直在准备，整理我新的那一小时内容。
But there's so much material from COVID, you know, trying to have sex during COVID. I had to get my own COVID test at my house. And then I would invite men over to the backyard that I was getting set up with or whatever. And I'd give them a little nasal swab and it takes like 20 to 30 minutes to run the diagnostics on that. There's nothing sexier. And in that 20 to 30 minutes, I would interview them, you know, about, see if they were a potential penetrator. And if they said anything in that time that was annoying or I saw a pinky ring,
但新冠疫情期间有很多素材，你知道，试图在疫情期间做爱。我必须在家里自己做新冠检测。然后我会邀请男人们到后院，我安排好的那些人什么的。我会给他们做一个小鼻拭子，运行诊断需要20到30分钟。没有什么比这更性感的了。在那20到30分钟里，我会采访他们，你知道，看看他们是否是一个潜在的深入交流者。如果他们在那个时间说了什么令人讨厌的话，或者我看到了小指戒指，
I would just come back out and say, you're positive. You have to leave my house. A pinky ring. If anybody mentioned an aquarium, they're positive. Like just, yeah. Anybody who said masks don't work. It's like, get out of my house. I can no longer fuck you.
我会直接走出来说，你是阳性。你必须离开我的房子。小指戒指。如果有人提到水族馆，他们就是阳性。就像，是的。任何说口罩没用的人。就像，滚出我的房子。我不能再和你做爱了。
Right, right. Hey, Charles, when, when you go on tour, like you are, and do you have like a thing after the show's over where you like, like any rituals or anything where you meet and greet, where you come back to the, to the hotel where you are, do you do something or just like straight to bed or how late to stay up? Yeah, I do a VIP meet and greet for other people that, you know, get the best tickets.
对，对。嘿，查尔斯，当，当你像现在这样去巡演时，演出结束后你有什么仪式吗，比如见面会，或者回到你住的酒店，你会做些什么，还是直接睡觉，或者熬到多晚？是的，我为那些买了最好票的人做VIP见面会。
You know, we do pictures after, but you know, when you're on tour, it's pretty grueling. Like being on stage for an hour and a half a night or an hour or whatever it ends up being is, like I'm 46 years old, so I got to keep it tight. I don't really, you know, go out and party like I used to when I was on the road where it didn't matter. And I, you know, it didn't matter. You just, now it's like, you want to be sharp.
你知道，我们之后会拍照，但你知道，当你巡演时，这很累人。比如每晚在舞台上待一个半小时或一小时，无论最终是多久，我46岁了，所以我得保持状态。我真的不会，你知道，像我以前在路上那样出去聚会，那时无所谓。而且我，你知道，那无所谓。你只是，现在就像，你想保持敏锐。
You want to have mental clarity. So no, I don't really get after it in that way. And then it's like usually four nights a weekend, you know, Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday night. Right. Do you ever go out and see other people stand up? Do you ever? Yeah, yeah, I do. I have been lately.
你想保持精神清晰。所以不，我真的不会那样去折腾。而且通常是一个周末四晚，你知道，周四、周五、周六、周日晚上。对。你去看过别人的单口喜剧吗？你有吗？是的，是的，我有。最近有。
Like anybody you're a fan of now? Yeah, a lot of standups. There's Hannah. I have a lot of amazing women opening for me. Hannah Einbinder is awesome from hacks. She opens for me. She opened for me in Vegas. Vanessa Gonzalez is a great female standup.
比如你现在喜欢的任何人？是的，很多单口喜剧演员。有汉娜。有很多很棒的女性为我开场。汉娜·艾因宾德在《绝望写手》里很棒。她为我开场。她在拉斯维加斯为我开场。凡妮莎·冈萨雷斯是一位很棒的女性单口喜剧演员。
A lot of women of color are opening for me, obviously, because that's, you know, my, my, do you want to give that stage time to everybody who hasn't gotten a fair shake at it? Yeah, for sure. And yeah, I just use different people all the time. And I just love to bring girls in. And yeah.
很多有色人种女性为我开场，显然，因为那是，你知道，我的，你想把舞台时间给每一个没有得到公平机会的人吗？是的，当然。是的，我一直用不同的人。我只是喜欢带女孩们进来。是的。
I love that. I mean, what was the question, Sean? No, that's it. Yeah, Sean, what was the fucking question? He wants to know what you do after, because we're going to do a real stupid thing. We're going to go on tour. Like, like, like, we're dumbasses.
我喜欢那样。我是说，问题是什么，肖恩？不，就是这样。是的，肖恩，他妈的问题是什么？他想知道你之后做什么，因为我们要去做一件真正愚蠢的事。我们要去巡演。就像，就像，我们是笨蛋。
And so Sean, I guess, is trying to figure out what his post-show routine is going to be. He wants to base it off what you do. And he wants to know, like, can he, can we hit the bars? Can he, can he mingle it up with people? Like, what's the deal? Or maybe just go back to the hotel, get in the Schvitz and, and where he's got to do like,
所以肖恩，我想，是在试图弄清楚他的演出后例行公事是什么。他想以你的做法为基础。他想知道，比如，他能去酒吧吗？他能和人们混在一起吗？情况是怎样的？或者也许只是回酒店，去蒸个桑拿，然后他得做点什么，
no, Scotty, I'm at home and like, shut up, you guys. I don't know. Well, these two guys, these two guys are sober. So they're not going to be going out with you, right? We can drive. We can drive him. Yeah. Maybe we'll drive you around.
不，斯科蒂，我在家，闭嘴，你们这些家伙。我不知道。好吧，这两个家伙，这两个家伙是清醒的。所以他们不会和你一起出去，对吧？我们可以开车。我们可以开车送他。是的。也许我们会开车送你到处转转。
You can go get after it. Actually, Sean, it depends how much you're contributing during the live shows, you know, if it's as much as you've been contributing to the podcast, yeah, you'll be free to do whatever you want. You'll have plenty of energy. You don't have to answer. Thank you.
你可以去折腾。其实，肖恩，这取决于你在现场演出期间贡献了多少，你知道，如果像你在播客中贡献的那么多，是的，你可以自由做任何你想做的事。你会有充足的精力。你不需要回答。谢谢。
By the way, Chels, thank you for managing expectations as we move forward. You know, what do you think? Chelsea, I do want to ask you, like you've, you kind of had a bunch of different careers. Like you've been a, you're a standup and you're a standup. You didn't start as a standup though. Is that right?
顺便说一句，切尔斯，谢谢你在我们前进时管理期望。你知道，你怎么看？切尔西，我确实想问你，你好像有过很多不同的职业。比如你是个单口喜剧演员，你是个单口喜剧演员。你不是从单口喜剧开始的，对吧？
I mean, you did it originally, but then you kind of became known also as you were, you had your show obviously that was hugely successful. And now you've kind of come back to standup and you've had, you had their show on Netflix as well. And you've gotten very political. Like you haven't had like a sort of a orthodox career. Not that anybody really does.
我是说，你最初做了，但后来你变得出名也是因为你，你显然有你的节目，非常成功。现在你又回到了单口喜剧，你也有了Netflix上的节目。而且你变得非常政治化。你没有那种正统的职业生涯。并不是说真的有人有。
My point is where do you see yourself? Like what kind of shit do you want to do? I don't know. In the next five years or 10 years, do you think it's going to interest you outside of just touring and shit? Like doing another show, like a late night show or some shit, you know?
我的意思是，你如何看待自己？你想做些什么样的事？我不知道。在未来五年或十年里，你认为除了巡演之类的，还有什么会让你感兴趣吗？比如做另一个节目，比如深夜秀之类的，你知道？
I did start out as a standup. That's how I got, you know, my show. So I did just to clarify that. I did start out, I did quit for a while when I burned myself out, when I went over to Netflix to do my documentary series and I had like a three or four year contract with them. So I did all of that stuff.
我确实是从单口喜剧开始的。这就是我得到，你知道，我的节目的方式。所以我只是澄清一下。我确实开始了，我确实辞职了一段时间，当我精疲力竭时，当我转到Netflix做我的纪录片系列时，我和他们签了三四年的合同。所以我做了所有那些事。
I did my shows, I did a bunch of documentaries and I just sold my last book, which is Life Will Be the Death of Me to a network for me to star in. I read that. So it's kind of like a career. Sorry to interrupt. How many books are you written?
我做了我的节目，我做了很多纪录片，我刚刚把我的最后一本书《生活将是我的终结》卖给了一个电视网，让我主演。我读过那个。所以这有点像职业生涯。抱歉打断一下。你写了多少本书？
I know you've written a bunch. Six. Amazing. Amazing. That's pretty fucking impressive. Six number one New York Times best sellers, guys. Six. Is that true?
我知道你写了很多。六本。太棒了。太棒了。这他妈太令人印象深刻了。六本《纽约时报》畅销书第一名，伙计们。六本。是真的吗？
Six number ones? Yeah. That's incredible. That's really impressive. That's very impressive. Thanks. I know. Sometimes I can't believe it.
六本第一名？是的。那太不可思议了。那真的很令人印象深刻。那非常令人印象深刻。谢谢。我知道。有时我不敢相信。
That's awesome. So you're adapting that into a show? Yeah. So it's kind of like a curb your enthusiasm, like with me in therapy, just constantly fucking up, trying to decunt, but never really being successful. I love that. It's another great title.
那太棒了。所以你要把它改编成节目？是的。所以它有点像《抑制热情》，就像我在接受治疗，不断地搞砸，试图去婊子化，但从未真正成功。我喜欢那个。那是另一个很棒的标题。
Think about that as a title. You just put like a weird symbol, phone symbol on there instead of the you and your goal. Oh yeah. I wake up, I have to wake up two hours earlier than everyone, you guys, just to decunt. I'm like, do not be a bitch today. You are one.
考虑一下那个标题。你只是在上面放一个奇怪的符号，电话符号，而不是那个U，你的目标。噢是的。我醒来，我必须比每个人早起两小时，你们这些家伙，只是为了去婊子化。我说，今天不要做个婊子。你就是一个。
Try not to be. Sure. And then a you with an umlaut and then you might be able to get away with it. You're done. Yep. Good call. Yeah. I'll use the Kardashian font so that they'll think it's part of that.
尽量不要。当然。然后一个带变音符号的U，那你可能就能蒙混过关了。你完成了。是的。好主意。是的。我会用卡戴珊字体，这样他们会以为那是其中的一部分。
So when, when do you start doing that? Are you, are you writing that now in script form? Yeah. Liz Tuchillo who's the right, the writer on it. She and I just sold it. So we're negotiating, you know, our deal. And yeah, we're, we're on it. I'm pretty excited.
所以你什么时候开始做那个？你现在在写剧本形式吗？是的。莉兹·图奇洛是编剧。她和我刚刚卖掉了它。所以我们正在协商，你知道，我们的合同。是的，我们，我们在做了。我很兴奋。
I've never played myself on TV. I've never really done a television show where it was acting for, you know, so I feel like I'm in that mode right now. You know, late night talk shows. I mean, every time I say, I'm not going to do something. I end up doing it. You know, so I don't want to say I'm never going to do that again, but I don't see myself interviewing.
我从来没在电视上演过我自己。我从来没真正做过那种需要表演的电视节目，所以我觉得我现在处于那种模式。你知道，深夜脱口秀。我是说，每次我说，我不会做某事。我最终还是做了。你知道，所以我不想说我永远不会再做那个了，但我看不出自己会去采访。
I like real people. Like I'm on my podcast, Dear Chelsea, people call in for advice. Like it was supposed to be a joke and it kind of turned into something serious because I am that kind of person. I like people to take risks and I like to be a cheerleader and a big sister and be like, go do that, break up with that guy, leave that job. You know, stop talking to your mother. So I just like that.
我喜欢真实的人。就像我在我的播客《亲爱的切尔西》上，人们打电话来寻求建议。就像那本该是个笑话，但它变成了一些严肃的东西，因为我就是那种人。我喜欢人们冒险，我喜欢做一个啦啦队长和一个大姐姐，说，去吧，和那个家伙分手，辞掉那份工作。你知道，别再和你妈妈说话了。所以我只是喜欢那样。
I like talking to real people. I like interpersonal stories and I've had my fair share of interviewing celebrities and now that we have social media, it's not like there's any mystique left in anybody or anything. So that genre for me or that medium, I should say, for me is no longer very exciting or challenging. You know, maybe something will happen to change that, but. What about acting?
我喜欢和真实的人交谈。我喜欢人际故事，我采访过足够多的名人，现在我们有了社交媒体，好像任何人或任何事都没有神秘感了。所以那个类型对我来说，或者我应该说那个媒介，对我来说不再那么令人兴奋或具有挑战性了。你知道，也许会发生什么改变这一点，但是。表演呢？
What about, where does acting sit for you playing somebody completely different? Does that have any interest to you or is that sort of the antithesis of what you're interested in? If it were fun and it was a challenge. Yeah. I mean, I do stuff. You know, I was going to do this Netflix movie where I played a principal of an elementary school that hated children and I was like, oh, that's a fun role. Like I could get off on that.
表演呢，对你来说处于什么位置，扮演一个完全不同的人？那对你有任何兴趣吗，还是那是你感兴趣的东西的对立面？如果它很有趣，而且是一个挑战。是的。我是说，我做过一些事。你知道，我本来要拍这部Netflix电影，我扮演一个讨厌孩子的小学校长，我说，噢，那是个有趣的角色。就像我能从中得到乐趣。
You know, but then I couldn't do it with my tour and COVID. You have to come in and out of Vancouver. But I am always open to things like that. But, you know, it's not my, it's not my jam. It's, you know, I don't, I'm not, I don't consider myself an actress at all, but I love to have a nice challenge. Right. Right.
你知道，但后来我因为巡演和新冠疫情没法做。你必须进出温哥华。但我总是对那样的事情持开放态度。但是，你知道，那不是我的，那不是我的菜。它，你知道，我不，我不认为自己是个女演员，但我喜欢接受一个好的挑战。对。对。
Yeah. I love that. You know, who's acting I love, who I texted him about his acting as Jason, when I was watching Ozarks, I was, I was, first of all, I was on a panel with Laura Linney for a Goop, a Goop panel for Gwyneth. And in New York City, this was like three or four years ago. Laura Linney, Drew Barrymore and a couple of other girls. And they were talking about parenting and, you know, we all had microphones in our
是的。我喜欢那个。你知道，我喜欢谁的表演，我给他发过关于他表演的短信，是杰森，当我在看《黑钱胜地》时，我，我，首先，我和劳拉·琳妮一起参加了一个Goop小组，一个为格温妮丝准备的Goop小组。在纽约市，这是三四年前的事了。劳拉·琳妮、德鲁·巴里摩尔和其他几个女孩。她们在谈论育儿，你知道，我们手里都有麦克风。
hand and Laura Linney told the story about how difficult she, what a difficult time she had getting pregnant and that they're going to say difficult time working with Jason, but yeah, keep going. Yeah. That too. She mentioned that too. And she, that was why she couldn't get pregnant was because of Jason is what she said. She said it was difficult to explain what a Goop panel was to people in the street or
劳拉·琳妮讲了一个故事，关于她有多困难，她怀孕有多困难，他们会说和杰森一起工作有多困难，但是的，继续。是的。那也一样。她也提到了那个。而且她，那就是她为什么不能怀孕的原因，是因为杰森，她是这么说的。她说很难向街上的人解释什么是Goop小组，或者
no, that was easy. Yeah. Yeah. She mentioned that too. Yeah. And, but she talked about giving birth when she goes, you know, I struggled for so long and then I finally gave birth when I was 50 and I went into the microphone, like loudly and, and, and Laura Linney looked at me and I just went, congratulations.
不，那很容易。是的。是的。她也提到了那个。是的。而且，但她谈到了分娩，她说，你知道，我挣扎了那么久，然后我终于在50岁时生了孩子，我对着麦克风，很大声地，而且，而且，劳拉·琳妮看着我，我只是说，恭喜。
I'm sorry. I just, that is so disgusting to me. But I, back to Laura and Jason on screen, I have to say is one of my favorite shows on television because I just love watching Jason. Love it. Love it. Nice lady. Thank you.
抱歉。我只是，那对我来说太恶心了。但回到屏幕上的劳拉和杰森，我不得不说这是我电视上最喜欢的节目之一，因为我就是喜欢看杰森。喜欢它。喜欢它。好女士。谢谢。
He's very, very good. Isn't he? We give him a lot of shit, but we love him. He's so good at what he does. I love him. Very charismatic, Jason. Always. Very, very on screen.
他非常，非常好。不是吗？我们给了他很多压力，但我们爱他。他所做的事非常出色。我爱他。非常有魅力，杰森。总是。非常，非常在屏幕上。
Very charismatic on screen. Very on screen. Yeah. Definitely on screen. No, but in person, it's a surprising dud. It's pretty, it's pretty quiet. Yeah. This is a lot of hate.
在屏幕上非常有魅力。非常在屏幕上。是的。绝对在屏幕上。不，但在现实中，是个令人惊讶的笨蛋。非常，非常安静。是的。这有很多恨意。
Chelsea, thank you for your time. I know you're probably exhausted and this is the last thing you wanted to do today, but thanks for stopping by. You're hilarious. It was cool of you to say yes. It was such an original and original voice and where you think that you're a CUNT, we think that you're hilarious and opinionated and awesome. So thank you.
切尔西，谢谢你的时间。我知道你可能精疲力竭，这是你今天最不想做的事，但谢谢你过来。你太搞笑了。你能答应真是太酷了。这是一个如此原创和原创的声音，在你认为你是婊子的地方，我们认为你很搞笑、有主见而且很棒。所以谢谢你。
Thank you guys. So much fun to see you all. Thank you, Chelsea. Very much. Great to see you. Have a great rest of the tour. Even you, Sean. Even you, Sean.
谢谢你们。见到你们所有人太有趣了。谢谢，切尔西。非常感谢。很高兴见到你。祝剩下的巡演顺利。即使是你，肖恩。即使是你，肖恩。
Wake up, bro. Bye, Chelsea. Bye. Hello, friends. Yeah. Chelsea Handler, ladies and gentlemen. Yep. So funny.
醒醒，兄弟。再见，切尔西。再见。你好，朋友们。是的。切尔西·汉德勒，女士们先生们。是的。太搞笑了。
Chelsea's so funny. Boy, she makes me laugh. I know. She makes me laugh, too. She always does. She's fearless. She's super funny. She's super quick.
切尔西太搞笑了。天哪，她让我大笑。我知道。她也让我大笑。她总是这样。她无所畏惧。她超级搞笑。她超级敏捷。
She wakes me up. She's very consistent. Always has lots of energy and ready to go. Even in casual conversation, you feel like, I got to be on my fucking toes because she will burn me. She'll correct me. She corrected you, Sean. She's corrected me before on stuff.
她让我清醒。她非常一致。总是充满活力，准备出发。即使在随意的谈话中，你也会觉得，我得时刻保持警惕，因为她会烧我。她会纠正我。她纠正了你，肖恩。她以前也纠正过我。
She lives for it. Hey, man. I love it. If I wanted to be with my mom, I'd go back to Toronto. Like, why are you correcting me? But if you like to sling bullshit, you're in the wrong room with her. Yeah, I know. She's quick.
她以此为生。嘿，伙计。我喜欢它。如果我想和我妈妈在一起，我会回多伦多。就像，你为什么要纠正我？但如果你喜欢胡说八道，那你和她在一起就走错房间了。是的，我知道。她很快。
Yeah. I do like that about her. It's pretty refreshing. You don't have to worry about talking about the weather because it's just, that's not going to cut it with her. Yeah. Yeah. I know.
是的。我确实喜欢她这一点。这很令人耳目一新。你不必担心谈论天气，因为那，那对她来说没用。是的。是的。我知道。
Love it. A better show is great, too. Of course it is. Oh. Every incarnation of talk shows. She's so fucking funny. Yeah. And she does.
喜欢它。更好的节目也很棒。当然是。噢。脱口秀的每一个化身。她太他妈搞笑了。是的。而且她确实。
I feel like she says the thing that everybody wants to say. And Anne says it in a way, she's always surprising. That's the thing it is. For me, it's always surprising what she says. Like, catches me off guard, really funny, you know, really just, she says things so succinctly, much unlike what I'm doing right now. Yeah. Nice job.
我觉得她说出了每个人都想说的话。而且安以一种方式说出来，她总是令人惊讶。这就是它的所在。对我来说，她说的总是令人惊讶。就像，让我措手不及，真的很搞笑，你知道，真的只是，她说话非常简洁，和我现在做的完全不同。是的。干得好。
Who's thinking of the buy right now? I am right now, but I think we need to start working on words that Ryan with buy. Oh, now see, I was more interested in just connecting with you guys. I wasn't thinking about how to wrap it up. No, you know why I brought it up because I could see the look on Sean's face. It looked like he'd been lobotomized. Well, he was writing. He's been writing for like 30 seconds, trying to figure out things that run with stuff.
谁在想那个“再见”？我现在在想，但我认为我们需要开始研究和“再见”押韵的词。噢，现在看，我更感兴趣的是和你们建立联系。我没想过怎么收尾。不，你知道我为什么提这个吗，因为我能看到肖恩脸上的表情。看起来他好像被切除了脑叶。好吧，他在写。他已经写了30秒了，试图找出和东西押韵的词。
That's what he does. You were talking, he was like this. He's just trying to think about it. No, you guys. Almost like he's got like an over buy. No. I have. Here it comes.
这就是他做的。你在说话，他就像这样。他只是在想。不，你们这些家伙。几乎就像他有某种过度购买。不。我有。它来了。
I have both. Eyes. Open eyes. What? I don't think we're going to, are you saying open eyes? Here's what's funny. Anytime I try to do it, I get shot down. And you always go real high.
我有两个。眼睛。睁开眼睛。什么？我不认为我们会，你是说睁开眼睛？有趣的是。每当我尝试这样做，我就会被拒绝。而且你总是走得很高。
I don't know why. Why does it look high for you? I'll go down here. Eyes. I don't know what the word you're saying is. And also, because you... Here comes Will. Will's going to try right now.
我不知道为什么。为什么它对你来说看起来很高？我会去这里。眼睛。我不知道你在说什么词。而且，因为你……威尔来了。威尔现在要尝试一下。
I'm not trying. What I'm saying is, Sean, sometimes you'll try to shoehorn it in. Yeah. Right? You know what I mean? Yeah. And it just doesn't qualify. It doesn't qualify.
我不是在尝试。我想说的是，肖恩，有时你会试图强行塞进去。是的。对吧？你知道我的意思吗？是的。而且它根本不合格。它不合格。
Yeah. We're going to sit here until we get one. I don't know. How did we back into this, by the way? Should we run the tapes back? When did this all start? Was it on the first episode? The very first one, yeah.
是的。我们要坐在这里直到我们得到一个。我不知道。顺便问一下，我们是怎么退回到这一点的？我们应该把磁带倒回去吗？这一切是什么时候开始的？是在第一集吗？第一集，是的。
What did we just do? A simple buy? Well, we could do it once. Yeah. We could do a simple buy or we could just agree to do it once a year or we could even do it buy annually. No. We used that one.
我们刚才做了什么？一个简单的再见？好吧，我们可以做一次。是的。我们可以做一个简单的再见，或者我们可以同意一年做一次，或者我们甚至可以每年做两次。不。我们用过那个了。
Why? Have we used that already? Buy annually. That doesn't even count. We've used every single one. That's why I wonder if we should do rhymes or just say buy. How about we just... Listener, we appreciate your time.
为什么？我们已经用过那个了吗？每年两次。那甚至不算。我们用过每一个了。这就是为什么我想知道我们应该做押韵还是只说再见。我们要不就……听众，我们感谢你的时间。
Yeah, we do. Or we'll... Why don't you give them... Well, listener, we've taken up too much of your time. Shut up, Arnett. Why don't you get a fucking new goodbye line for our guests, by the way. Okay? I got notes for you.
是的，我们感谢。或者我们会……为什么你不给他们……好吧，听众，我们占用了你太多时间。闭嘴，阿内特。顺便说一句，为什么你不给我们的嘉宾换个他妈的新告别语。好吗？我有笔记给你。
What are you talking about? Why are you taking too much of your time? Shut up. I don't say this. How about it's an hour and we're done. Yeah, we're done. So thank you for your answers. Who do I say that to?
你在说什么？为什么你占用太多时间？闭嘴。我不这么说。要不就说一小时到了，我们结束了。是的，我们结束了。所以谢谢你的回答。我对谁说那个？
You mean I say that to the guest? I'm just as bad. I say, oh gosh. No, you always say, oh my gosh. What do you got? Nothing on there. How much did you pay them? Shut the fuck up, man.
你是说我对嘉宾说那个？我也一样糟糕。我说，噢天哪。不，你总是说，噢天哪。你有什么？上面什么都没有。你付了他们多少钱？闭嘴，伙计。
Yeah, I know. All right. And we're going to get into this. And you two chuckles. Yeah, Sean, we're coming for you next. So quiet down. Yeah, you're fucking next, Sean. Fuck both of you.
是的，我知道。好吧。我们要进入这个了。还有你们两个傻瓜。是的，肖恩，我们接下来要找你。所以安静点。是的，你他妈是下一个，肖恩。去你们两个的。
How's that for low and not high? Oh, whoa, whoa. Who is this guy? It's almost like he was about to bite our head off. Oh my god. The fuck was that? Smart. Smart.
那作为低而不高怎么样？噢，哇，哇。这家伙是谁？简直就像他要咬掉我们的头一样。天哪。那他妈是什么？聪明。聪明。
smart. Smart. Smart. smart. smart. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjörv and Bennett Barbico. at Barbago. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts,
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartList是100%有机的，由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆约夫和贝内特·巴比科手工制作。在巴比戈。我们的下一集将在下周播出，无论你在哪里听播客，
or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry App. Smart Loss. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者你现在就可以在Amazon Music上提前收听，或者通过订阅Apple Podcasts或Wondry App中的Wondry Plus提前且无广告地收听。Smart Loss。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。